>>> HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY WILL NOT SUPPORT A 9/11
COMMISSION TO STUDY THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION OR INVESTIGATE IT.
HE WROTE, QUOTE, GIVEN THE
POLITICAL MISDIRECTIONS THAT
HAVE MARRED THIS AND THE
DUPLICATIVE AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE NATURE OF THIS
EFFORT AND GIVEN THE SPEAKER'S
SHORTSIDED SCOPE, I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
LEGISLATION, BY THE WAY,
NEGOTIATED BY A REPUBLICAN, JOHN
KATKO OF NEW YORK.
BACK WITH US, GLORIA BORGER.
SO THERE YOU HAVE IT.
McCARTHY IS AGAINST IT.
>> I THINK IT'S A COMPLETE
ABDICATION OF HIS POLITICAL
RESPONSIBILITY, OF HIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO HISTORY, AND
TO EVERY PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY
WHO NEEDS TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
NOT ONLY IS IT AN ABDICATION BUT
HE ALSO THREW HIS OWN PERSON,
CONGRESSMAN KATKO, A REPUBLICAN,
WHO NEGOTIATED THIS IN GOOD
FAITH, WITH DEMOCRATS, SO THEY
COULD COME UP WITH A WAY TO DO
AN INVESTIGATION THAT WOULD BE
BIPARTISAN.
AND IN SAYING HE DOESN'T SUPPORT
IT, HE'S SAYING TO REPUBLICANS,
OKAY, GO OUT AND SAY WHATEVER
YOU WANT ABOUT IT AND WE KNOW
THAT, JUST LAST WEEK, THERE WERE
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE OUT THERE
SAYING THAT THE INSURRECTION WAS
EFFECTIVELY A WALK IN THE PARK
BY A BUNCH OF TOURISTS.
IT GIVES THEM PERMISSION TO KEEP
TELLING THESE LIES.
>> HE'S TRYING TO, GLORIA,
PRETEND IN A WAY THAT THIS
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THAT IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
WARRANTS REALLY AN
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS WHAT
MANY REPUBLICANS BELIEVE.
HE TALKS ABOUT THERE BEING
MISDIRECTIONS.
THE MISDIRECTIONS ARE COMING
FROM HIS PARTY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND IT'S JUST AN EXCUSE.
IT'S AN EXCUSE.
IT'S AN EXCUSE TO SAY WE DON'T
WANT TO LOOK BACK.
EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT JANUARY
6th, IT'S NOT GOOD FOR US,
REPUBLICANS, AND MAYBE McCARTHY
COULD BE SUBPOENAED, FOR
EXAMPLE, TO TALK ABOUT HIS
CONVERSATION WITH DONALD TRUMP
THAT DAY.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT POINT.
YOU ARE GETTING THIS STATEMENT,
THIS OPPOSITION FROM A POTENTIAL
WITNESS WHO MIGHT BE ASKED TO
APPEAR UNDER SUBPOENA AND
TESTIFY UNDER OATH.
>> YES.
AND WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID TO HIM THAT DAY.
AND WHAT McCARTHY SAID BACK TO
HIM THAT DAY, AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT WOULDN'T LOOK GOOD FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND I THINK
McCARTHY WANTS TO AVOID ALL OF
THAT COMPLETELY.
>> YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
IS A TIME WHERE THE CONGRESS
NEEDS TO REALLY BE REFLECTING ON
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT WHAT
PROMPTED JANUARY 6th TO HAPPEN,
GLORIA, IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
HAS GONE BY THE WAYSIDE.
THIS IS STILL VERY MUCH A
CONCERN.
YOU DO -- WE JUST HEARD REVEREND
FRANKLIN GRAHAM TALKING ABOUT
HOW MANY AMERICANS, AS HE
BREATHED LIFE INTO THE BIG LIE
HIMSELF, HOW MANY AMERICANS HAVE
CONCERNS, AS HE PUT IT, ABOUT
THE ELECTION.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING AWAY.
I TRY TO THINK OF -- IMAGINE
THERE NOT BE A 9/11 COMMISSION.
IMAGINE THERE NOT BE A LOOK INTO
WHAT HAPPENED FOR THE SAKE OF
HISTORY AND FOR MAKING SURE THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS AND
SIGNIFICANT.
THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> RIGHT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU HAVE
HAD OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC TERRORISM AS
ONE OF THE LARGEST PROBLEMS THAT
WE ARE FACING IN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW.
NOR THAN 400 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED OR CHARGED IN TERMS OF
THE INSURRECTION THAT WE SAW ON
JANUARY 6th.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS TO GET
ANSWERS ABOUT THIS.
AND I KNOW THAT REPUBLICANS IN
THE HOUSE WANT TO BROADEN THIS
SO THEY CAN SAY, OKAY, THERE'S A
LOT OF IT GOING ON, ON BOTH
SIDES.
I MEAN, WE UNDERSTAND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WHAT THE COUNTRY WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT NOW AND UNDERSTAND IS JUST
HOW JANUARY 6th OCCURRED AND
WHAT WAS BEHIND IT.
THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO
INVESTIGATE EVERYTHING.
>> LOOK, NOW WE HAVE TO WATCH TO
SEE AND LISTEN FOR WHAT MITCH
McCONNELL HAS TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
McCART